i blame millennials well i blame uh
boomers well millennials what are they
doing
i mean they're trying to make it i think
most people yeah i guess but like how
many millennials are actually running
for office
you're they're doing it they are but
they get their i'll they're doing
they're complaining on the internet
these these these you know guys putting
up like cameras in their bedrooms and
then doing these youtube shows where
they bring people in all they do is talk
talk talk talk probably wear a beanie 24
7.
not running for office not leading the
charge
but the thing is that when you have
institutional power i know so many
politicians who they doubt
they never want to leave i mean joe
biden was in office for a
hundred thousand years he's been office
for something like 25 of the history of
the country and he never once leave it
there was
probably other people incentive to
delaware but they were never gonna be
ousted by they're not gonna oust joe
biden
they're never gonna oust mitch mcconnell
mitch mcconnell is like a turtle i mean
he literally is like 300 years old
dianne feinstein is in her mid-90s and
she is just
there forever and it's just
there are sure there's young people in
california who want to run for office
rokana could be that position but yeah
but
they never they never get the
opportunity because people just stay
forever
and i'm not supportive of term limits so
it's i'm not endorsing that but i mean
you never want to let that stage go
something did weird did happen because i
pulled up this thing from
uh pew about the generational gap in
politics 2018 was interesting we're
seeing a lot more
younger people there's uh what was it
madison cawthorne
aoc obviously you're getting a lot more
younger people who are coming in
but there really was a period where
millennials
and i'm not going to blame gen z they're
not quite at that point yet but
millennials are entering their for
getting close to their 40s yeah we only
have a handful
and who's and who's doing anything
substantive in politics and culture
leading the church so as much as i can
make fun of myself
like why i think what we're doing is
important we're engaging in civics we're
engaging in politics
we're communicating with other
millennials and talk about these issues
obviously the people who are watching
are engaged but there is a
large large portion of millennials who
are just abstaining
from politics well i mean but look at
them i mean and i'm not giving excuses
to people out but we did get
we did get it rough we came into age
during the oa crisis we did and then we
got the and then we got the
i mean covet into our 30. there was a
lot of speed bumps that we hit on the
way to adulthood
that's why i was going to say maybe i
blame boomers a bit boomers definitely
deserve a lot of blame for a lot of
things they held onto power for too long
they misguided it they had these large
notions they didn't have the sense of
duty the way that
or they didn't expand the sense of duty
that that
their parents didn't think aren't they
hippies yeah they're the hippie
generation
some of them always percentage though
look but could you imagine this
generation geriatric boomers as i'm a
german
geriatric millennial i've been told yeah
could you imagine these these you know
boomers who are like hippies
who are partying and you know like live
free free love
and then as soon as they got older they
were like mine my stuff
yeah and listen to dr fauci right that's
i mean that is
literally who they became is everything
they have heard that the hippie movement
really got derailed by the drugs
like they just did too many and they
just it's fun as it was but they
people that have looked back were like
if we hadn't done all the drugs we would
have been able to have a political
movement for real
well i'm sure i'm sure that when i mean
when you go around the pentagon and try
to elevate it with your levitated with
your brain
eventually is that what they did yeah
yes that was famous they went they were
on they're trying to levitate the
pentagon
who was that was david leary right it
didn't work that didn't surprisingly
it wasn't like that ball it keeps
levitating it didn't happen so i mean
well hold on hold on but was it like
were they doing like light as a feather
stiff as a board
where you get like seven million i don't
think they can hold underneath the event
but they but no this is a famous you
know yeah i think david leary was like
trying to levitate the pentagon with
their brain i believe it was david leary
but yeah
i mean they timothy tim timothy leary
timmy lear not dave lee or david lee or
something he was like one of the
pioneers of lsd
yeah yeah it's timothy leary i think he
tried to levitate we got it from
smithsonian mag
yeah 50 years ago a rag tag group of
acid dropping activists tried to
levitate the pentagon yes
imagine what you must have done wrong to
create a
generation where people all show up like
let's levitate the
building man and they're like nothing's
happening dude
did you do more acid let me try and you
know one guy was like wow it worked
like i mean one guy was like that
totally worth it
totally worth it
and we were levitating with it yeah yes
but i mean and that's the generation
that's out there and
hung on to institutional power and
wealth and they have way too much of it
and they
a and in a lot of ways they sold out a
lot of things that
gave them that ability to mask that
wealth because it made them wealthier i
mean like things like normalizing trade
relations with china and
you know stopping a lot of a lot of
other things as well
but yeah that's that's the boom the
bonuses have a lot of and there's a
great book by my co-podca i have a
podcast
with american conservative magazine
called right now my co-author
mike my co-podcast helen andrews wrote a
book called boomers
it's a great book so is it i'm gonna go
ahead and say
we can keep reducing the problem you
know trying to figure out where it's
rooted you can say
well the boomers who who who had the
boomers the greatest generation
yeah the silent generation silent
generation no silent was gen xers
no silent is like 1916.
no no it's silent but
the greatest generation was they came
back from world war ii you had a bunch
of babies yeah yeah
yes yes yes so what did the greatest
generation do wrong
that created a bunch of they made the
suburbs and that's that's where
everything went wrong
no i just think that i think that you
know if you grow up in the depression
and you grew up and
you went to world war ii which was a lot
of that generation growing through
really hard times worse than millennials
had it you kind of want
normalcy and you want and you probably
are
a little quieter in your beliefs and and
that was and that you don't sit there
and stimulate
you know overstimulate telling you know
a lot of things and also not all boomers
a lot of boomers went to vietnam and
they phoned a horrible war they should
have been a part of and like
some boomers did sacrifice a lot but the
overall
like me focus on me going to the suburbs
i need to have a bigger plot alone i
need to have
you know i think that definitely
affected a lot of people's psyche as a
part of like this is about me
because those boomers later on went on
to go because if they were born in the
40s
then they came of age voting for the you
know the me generation with reagan their
kids absorbed it big time which was the
exercise who was probably our better
generation we have alive today as the
xers
and i say that as a millennial but yes
yeah yeah yeah
because they were the most ignored the
extras never got attention bro they were
punk man
i think the greatest generation came
back from all this hardship overseas
and they were like i'm going to do
everything in my power to make sure that
my kids have
everything they want i want to live the
american dream i will raise them that
way i never want i want them to go to
college you know i don't want them
that might have been but they also
inherited their their they also
inherited the greatest generation
everything they built but also if you
grow up in depression
and war in really terrible situations
you
of course you want normalcy for your
account of course like that is your
natural instinct they built it on the
back of war spoils basically the us was
the only country that didn't get
leveled during world war ii our soil
didn't get invaded so we had massive
wealth
and they and they created a system on
top of that that could only subsist with
that
level of weapon but if you look at the
drop-off it it does decrease starting in
the 70s but when they normalize trade
relations in china and when they go into
nafta
you see it plummet and they catapult
nixon first off the gold standard
purely for that reason no nicknames for
the gold center because he couldn't
afford lbj's
spending deals and he couldn't also he
couldn't also pay for that anymore he
couldn't he couldn't repeal it
and he needed to get off the gold
standard i mean i don't bla i don't i
don't think that was a great choice but
i don't blame nixon for that because he
couldn't he couldn't get rid of the the
great society
and lbj is one of the worst presents of
all time millennials aren't
leading and i don't know if it's an
excuse to say well we had two
you know major economic crises i mean
people have their hardship
that what the boomers also had vietnam
didn't they yeah they had vietnam but
they also had
a massive amount of stability and i
think that i mean if you look at the
inequality between generations it's it's
huge right now
um and i definitely yeah boomers hold it
boomers hold
huge sums of wealth and it's not even
close to where millennials will ever be
this is crazy i saw uh 40 of millennials
have not had their first child yet and
they're going to the
and there was some data from a few years
ago that said uh people who are 29 are
have a net negative
a negative net worth of about a thousand
dollars and only at 30 do they go
positive
but i saw a meme i don't know if this is
true it's just a meme and they said mark
zuckerberg
accounts for two percent of all
millennial wealth oh my gosh that would
that would not surprise i mean that
would be
shocking number but it wouldn't surprise
me the other day two percent that's
that's a lot i mean it
sounds small but consider how many
millennials there are one guy
one guy is two percent well and and add
that to all of
all the people who came who came out of
the tech boom who like created like i
don't know how much time for my space is
worth but like
all those 100 okay but still if you add
all those people together who made
who made something became a billionaire
or 100 million or whatever and
accumulated together i'm sure they
they make up like a dozen people
probably make about significant half
yeah and that's that is that is
genuinely a
wild one look i i can i can look at the
older generation and blame them for not
instilling proper values
in millennials but when when you get
people who
think the path towards making money is
accruing hundreds of thousand dollars in
school debt
but you're sold on that from like from a
kid you're saying that's why you're
going to go to college and but at a
certain point there's got to be
responsibility for the individuals
so that's why i look at this like our
society sold a lie
to millennials and screwed them over so
i'm in favor of some kind of debt relief
that isn't just paying off everyone's
debt
so i i think maybe like terminating
interest rates pay down the principal
no more interest rates accrue you can
still defer because
how do you have a generation how do you
have a country
when an entire generation owns nothing
except for like mark zuckerberg
and they're saddled with a debt that
just keeps going up
well more importantly colleges should
have to co-sign their loans
yeah colleges should not call one we
should seize the endowments there's no
question
thank you harvard has 120 billion by
themselves tax-free
that they do nothing besides you know
institute the worst ideas in the society
but colleges should have to co-sign your
loan if they're gonna make you pay 200
grand for you know a degree in basket
weaving
they should co-sign that they should not
sit there and say oh you know yeah
best of luck to you on your path of uh i
don't know may becoming a brand who
sells best
i don't know anything but they should
have to co-sign your own because if they
did they would not give out
the nonsense degrees they do they would
not have the cost be as high as they do
um and they would perform something i
mean colleges get away with
a lot and also they're the it's they're
so hypocritical because it's like the
home of the biggest leftists the biggest
bleeding heart progressives
and every way the college administration
works
is like them is the most money grabbing
kind of organization
in the entire world it is like it is
like
a wolf of wall street would not be as
deceptive as college institutions are
and i say this is a college dropout so i
mean i'm not someone i didn't spend a
lot of time in academia but you see the
way it works
it is they they preach one thing and
they operate a completely different way
scam factories it is total scam it's
great to see colleges have an incentive
to get jobs for the students
that was the best that was the best
thing happening because of cove it was
some people dropped out of college and
they're like i'm not gonna go for a year
and figure something out i mean i
really hope some people figure something
out besides going to college because i
mean i
i also didn't go and i know i'm unique
how i make money whatever
but there has to be a path for people
outside going to university i mean
they're just there has to be
maybe we needed some kind of you know
like great
restart or or reset yeah but that's
some sort of reset yeah a great one i
was just like
it took me a second no but this is like
this is like where
this is where i talked to a congressman
from the midwest the other day about
this
you know they're always about
repatriating stuff from china now and
bringing back our health care and our
military stuff and our production value
actually building factories whatever
if you left that up to market forces
alone they would go to arizona texas
california for the shipping and the
newest and best
uh uh rail and all the rest roads
everything internet
um real infrastructure not like the bs
infrastructure that biden was
selling on like you know child care if
you really want to revive the places
who've been devastated
for up to 30 40 50 years of bad trade
agreements and
chinese manipulation all the rest of it
you need government power to sit there
and say okay
not only is this aspirin factory going
to come back to the united states
it's going to go to detroit and we're
going to figure out a way to make it
incentivize you go to detroit
it could be a tax thing it could be what
do you need you need better better wi-fi
you need five whatever you need
what do you need we're going to make you
go to akron ohio
or go to altoona pennsylvania or go to
erie pennsylvania these places that have
been
just there they are on the precipice of
annihilation as
as a people go you know and and that has
a whole psyche with
where you have you know in america in
our lifetime
the life expectancy was declining in
broad sections of the country
and this is in my book if you are born
they're not listening hallelujah the
national poppies revolution
um but if you were born in kentucky or
west virginia as a white person or the
mississippi delta as a black person or
in the native american reservations as a
native american person in south dakota
you're going to die 20 years before
someone is born in the suburbs of denver
colorado
that is just the huge discrepancy of
life expectancy
south dakota has the parts of dakota
have the lowest life expectancy
in the western hemisphere i i hear you
and i i understand that we probably do
have the resources to solve a lot of
these problems
but who's going to blow up the kids
overseas if you take the money away from
international excursions and you know
but no but it's not even i'm i'm bored
with you
they're 110 but you and i mean the army
is a jobs program in many aspects of it
but at the same time if you're gonna sit
there and have
if covid was going to sit there on
deficit or economy and we're going to
rebrand it and not every job being an
amazon job
and you want to actually improve the
lives of working-class people who have
been
from from urban areas to rural to
ex-urban who have been
devastated by our modern economy and and
by the modern system
you need government involvement you
can't leave up to the free market alone
and that's what the right is completely
missing in this entire moment i know
that's
we're on a toll well you see that with
the attack the mish mish management of
the tech you know
they don't even know what tech is i mean
literally it's a private company so it
can do it you can do whatever i want you
know
you know absolutely i it's it's it's
like seeing like a guy screw your wife
and say oh it's free will she wanted to
do it too like it's
they're saying that yes exactly like
yeah you know it's free well so she
you shouldn't be upset because it's it's
what she wanted it is
literally nuts what they're sitting
there and doing and they're they're
they're condoning
losing because it's very profitable in
the in the government sector to lose
it's very profitable you sell a lot more
books as the minority party
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you